cette lycéenne joue avec banshee
la mascotte d'une nouvelle application
en réalité augmentée qui présente les
métiers et formations de la cosmétique à
travers des jeux c'est bien pour les
lycéens pour pour tout le monde trouve
ça un peu trop collégiens légèrement ça
donne des idées parce que l'on connaît
pas forcément tous les métiers quand on
rentre dans la filière et c'est
justement le but de cette application
c'est vraiment de sensibiliser les
jeunes à ces métiers de la production de
faire découvrir l'industrie du parfum et
des cosmétiques
aujourd'hui le jeune il connaît les
magasins de distribution
le produit fini mais il n'a pas du tout
conscience mais même je parle du jeune
toujours mais du demandeur d'emploi il
n'a pas toujours conscience de toute la
filière de fabrication car la filière
manque de main d'oeuvre
malgré les quinze mille recrutement
cosmétiques en 2018 une étude a montré
que deux tiers des entreprises avaient
des difficultés à recruter sur des
postes comme conducteur de ligne ou
techniciens de maintenance
le constat est clair l'industrie
cosmétique n'attire pas partie de ce
constat là on avait besoin de
communiquer et il se trouve que tous les
outils de communication il en existe
effectivement plein mais à des endroits
différents
effectivement vous avez cité le cio ont
tort de bauxite et l'onisep on peut en
citer plein et en fait derrière on parle
pas de cosmétiques m'en parle de chimie
jamais on identifie la cosmétique
d'où le choix de créer cette application
qui rassemble les informations pour
communiquer et sensibiliser afin de
faire face aux besoins à venir
cinquante mille emplois seront créés
dans la filière cosmétique d'ici 2030